seaweed's seen as a waste product here
in my gate it often washes up on the
shore and it'll smell and it will decay
by us using it and harvesting it
ourselves and putting it into luxury
products we're able to create that
dialogue with the local community about
how it's not just a waste product it can
be a really beneficial one for the body
i really appreciate the fact that i can
be on the beach and
doing something good
for the community and call it work
[Music]
hackers currently exist as 100 natural
ingredient supply apps we create beauty
products skin care products and a whole
range of homework products as well every
product has a reason to exist that
allows us to not just be the seaweed
skincare brand that allows us to be that
progressive beauty brand that
concentrates on how we can amplify the
natural world how we can create
game-changing products and how we can
also pioneer new materials to present
the full package of sustainability and
beauty one of my favorite parts of the
job picking seaweed it's great to just
be on the beach
so i came in pretty quickly
so i've got bit wet seaweed grows in
abundance around the coast and the way
that we pick it we cut it from the
higher up on the front so that it can
regrow if the seaweeds just pulled off
the chalk reefs then it won't grow again
but we're very careful with the way that
we harvest
everything that we do tries to have a
positive impact on the environment and
the ocean and so we use the seaweed
that's available to us here we use
bladderwax vladirac has incredibly
nourishing antiseptic then we use kelp
kelp is incredibly calming and cooling
and soothing this one is serrated rack
seaweed contains a natural alginate so
it's really softening on the skin
really hydrating it also has a natural
iodine in it when it's used in our
seaweed wraps at the treatment rooms it
can really help with joint pain we do
like to collect different varieties as
it allows us to showcase the different
bioactive properties in the marine algae
around our coasts
we've got just under a box in here and
probably the same in this one
as well
we usually try and fill them up but the
tide's quite heavy as well so just make
sure we can have them back the plan now
is to take a box back to wash and dry
and the other box will go to the
treatment rooms for seaweed wraps and
seaweed baths
so i was getting some of the seaweed out
of the dehydrator now it's kind of all
kind of dried up
so this means we can now kind of ground
it down put it through the extraction
process my favorite product is the
perfumes the scents are based on
different locations around the kenk
coast they've got a great story and they
smell really good too we also try and
make everything surrounding that product
including the packaging and the way it's
distributed as sustainable as possible
too it's an industry dictated by excess
packaging it's an industry dictated by
plastic and litter pollution and
everything else but i think what we
would love for heckles is to be the
amplifier and the sharer of our
resources partnering up with sailor and
helping us to get that global platform
of how you can create a beautiful
skincare brand a beautiful home and
fragrance brand that's dictated by
nothing more than sustainability and
design and get it out there into a wide
audience
heckles has always been a pioneer of new
materials and we championed smaller
suppliers as well i think that hackles
is about to be on the cusp of some
really really new exciting innovations i
think it's always impossible to achieve
this mission as you scale so we've been
laser focused as to how we grow in a
sustainable manner how we constantly
highlight and amplify new materials and
new resources and how we never
overconsume anything out of the natural
world
we're gonna be excavated on the beach in
margaret and they'll find all the the
hecklers remember
[Music]